[Musique]
faux chatel à l'immobilière sur le
bouclier déflecteur arrière oui voilà
faisons ça
[Musique]
puis quand tu sait piloter à 190 ans
tu les fais pas joui prend le relais
tuer des landaus
[Musique]
battu avec un enfant il n'y a pas de
menteur sabac il ya des joueurs place
est libre
une personne est assise ce qu'est les
livres alors vous jouez au jeu bac à bac
à bac
d'accord vous y allez déjà joué
plusieurs fois capitaine lors d'autres
qualifiant en solo vous avez l'air dans
un bon jour je suis chanceux je peux
vous poser une question capitaine
qualifiant les ian nan nan mais c'est
pas grave on a raconté une histoire à
votre sujet je me demandais si elles
étaient vendues toutes les histoires
pourra concevoir sans vrai
réfléchis tu veux vraiment déplacé cela
tu veux vraiment déplacé le déplacement
très bien et donc être obligé que des
meulières ce petit bonhomme je sais pas
pourquoi cela serait de gagner
non tu peux pas les écrabouiller ses
dénigreurs relate s est maîtrisé il faut
toujours avoir quelques coups d'avancé
anticipé ceux de l'adversaire c'est ça
le secret c'est comme dans la vie
[Musique]
après quoi tu cours
la vengeance
l'argent
ou est-ce que c'est autre chose
et boum tu t'habilles toujours aussi mal
mais tu as l'air en forme m'a parlé d'un
boulot un gros bonnet qui veulent se
montrent une équipe
je suis pas qu'un chauffeur j'ai aussi
un pilote
longtemps que j'attendais de gaz comme
celle là
qu'est ce que t'en dis n'importe quoi
c'est au trouver un vaisseau ouais je
connais quelqu'un c'est le roi de la
contrebande
on va raconter une histoire à ton sujet
je me demandais si c'était vrai toutes
les histoires pour raconter à mon sujet
fait trois l'achète et monsieur
[Musique]
si tu viens avec nous tu as une grande
carrière devant toi sois gentil attache
pour mon bras
[Musique]
voilà
je peux te donner un concert
pars du principe que tout le monde
craint
je serai jamais déçu
je sais pas pourquoi mais je le sens
bien
[Musique]
depuis quand us à piloter oui 190 en
plein tu les fais pas vasic
[Musique]
je suis trop contente est large